this man is a heisman trophy finalist
and he's also the quarterback of the top
ranked team going into the college
football playoffs he is uh right here on
the rich his show for the very first
time um mercedes-benz vans phone line
bryce young is here how are you
sir um
are you there you're you must be on a
cell phone you're cutting in and out you
there
yeah ah
there you are yeah it sounds kind of i'm
not sure if you can hear me
you wanna do why don't you do me a favor
can you would you mind calling back
right now is that okay
yeah can we do that yeah for sure i'll
call that well you do that there you go
there's bryce young
there we go he's gonna yeah i feel like
that's kind of like the
top of the first quarter of the sec
championship game a little shaky
based off of the outset of there being a
bad connection that's not going to
happen but he's going to call back and
it's going to be the greatest interview
we've ever had i think you're right
it's just like the sec championship game
right there it was pretty good did you
like that one i did
oh the freezing cold takes people like
alabama's just not can't hang with him
it's rare to see alabama on the same
field with the team that they that's
they're far
worse than
i got to say it was 10 nothing and i was
counting my money
i'm like yeah you really though come on
against alabama looked over they looked
they looked like they couldn't do
anything over it looked like they
couldn't do anything
georgia moved right down the field
i was like sweet
this week's done
dude what am i betting on sunday like i
guess i guess when you're not
emotionally invested you have clearer
eyes and fuller hearts you know what i
mean yeah
because you were like michigan's this
game's over against iowa and i'm like
shut up i don't wanna hear another thing
i'm gonna exchange with you i watched
the quarter iowa couldn't move the ball
that game was a wrap right
right
and then i saw that game and i'm like
georgia's
might win today i don't know yet man i
need to see this
and then
half an hour later that thing was that
thing was
wrapped
we should have known better though man
like
it's alan
when was the last time alabama had been
it had been like 90-something games
since they were underdogs okay bryce
young back here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line you
there bryce yeah
hey
here we go baby it sounds like you're
right next to me bryce like the third
quarter
it really does yeah that was
we were just saying this is kind of like
the sec championship game is a little
shaky at first but everything turns out
in the end right pretty much right there
pretty much this how are you doing
i'm blessed i'm blessed i'm doing well
thank you for asking how are you guys uh
you know what um i'm good uh i'm i'm i'm
ready to roll i'm you know getting ready
for week 14 of the nfl season i'm full
disclosure i'm a university of michigan
alum so life is pretty good um at some
point um you know if you know the
football gods smile maybe january 10th
we're we're having another conversation
you and i yeah you know sir that's the
goal so what uh what is it like to
uh
be coached by nick saban bryce
yeah i mean it's it's definitely it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to be
able to clock in at work every day go on
the field and know you know you're being
coached by the best um you know to know
that you know that's someone that's
always going to demand a high standard
from all of us from you know myself
individual us as a team someone that you
know has seen everything has coached the
best been in the biggest moments and
situations and have the opportunity to
pick his brain and and you know and and
take the coaching and be able to grow
underneath him
and and the things that he chooses the
position he puts me in the
things he chooses you know to tell me
during practice the inside he gives me
um you know it's it's the best thing you
can ask for as a college player the uh
the insight what is the insight can you
give me an example of that insight i
mean there's all types of stuff whether
it's little tips on hey if a corners if
you see safety rotation like this i'm
you know this is you know
you got to expect this type of coverage
it could be situational stuff in game as
far as you know make sure you you know
the clock this is the situation make
sure that we we we don't want to give
the ball back or um we want to make sure
that we're burning as much clock or you
know this is a situation where we can
take a shot because we have another
whatever it may be um again that's
someone who's a master of situations has
been in every single
been in every situation seeing every
coverage seeing everything um so again
for me to be able to you know get get
some of that knowledge and be able to
coach brian on a daily basis um i mean
it's it's helped me grow tremendously
has he ever told you about his friend
bofa bryce has he ever gone there with
you on that front
i've been been here too long to fall for
something like that
[Laughter]
okay yeah because we we heard about that
uh earlier this year from one of your uh
from one of your colleagues so um what
was the recruiting process like with
alabama
yeah um ironically it was um it was it
was an interesting process actually um i
first got offered by university of
alabama um it was like it wasn't right
before it was like right during the
playoffs of my uh sophomore year of high
school am i taking a trip out here it
was like we had like a bye week right
before playoffs started taking a trip up
here um they had offered me and this
time it was like it was tosh uh it was
tosh lapoy was a whole different staff
and the funny thing i remember is when i
when i first came up here i was thinking
um and again this is this is me as a
sophomore
i'm thinking yeah i'll i i'll never be
there um you know i just didn't think i
never thought about going to the south
to the sec going to the south um i never
thought about um you know i to me i was
just
um you know i'd been in california my
whole life and i was just you know i was
just i had a few offers so i was just
hoping for you know maybe you know i'll
probably stay in the pac-12 or maybe um
you know something like that and then i
remember um that went on i committed to
usc and then
um
it was about say like the off-season
leading into my senior year um sark was
there um coach stark was who originally
recruited me and you know he's from
socal and i had known him through you
know just through other coaching stuff
through you know kind of mutual mutual
friends i just i you know i just been
around him and knew who he was of course
so um you know then he had reached out
and i started talking to him and then um
you know it changed as far as just um as
far as me just oh this is a great offer
obviously as a bama i just you know i'm
not really locked in i just want you
know i just wanted the offer i just
wanted to see the facilities to like
this is a real possibility this is
something that can you know that i have
to look at from a different lens and
then you know as i got around here i
started to kind of learn about and see
the culture i started to see you know
seeing the offense seeing how it worked
and feeling like it was a good fit for
me um you know i i ended up you know
that's what ended up leading me into you
know making that that decision i ended
up um
i ended up committing to alabama
like the fifth game of my senior year
and then um you know i've been it was
you know best decision i could possibly
make i would i i would think so uh what
was it like being in a quarterback room
with mac jones last year
yeah i know it was a huge learning
experience for me um
to see someone like mac and especially
when you're talking about in a meeting
room in the quarterback room to see how
he processes how he thinks about things
to see the preparation that he would put
in week in and week out you know to see
him on the board see how how comfortable
he was in the offense see how
comfortable he was talking about
defenses and and all that for me as
someone who was new to college um you
know i i i thought that you know that
was a strong suit of mine in high school
trying to be prepared being being smart
but seeing
that next level and that jump and this
is what you know and seeing obviously
the success that mac had last year and
the team had last year i saw okay this
is what's required this is standard this
is what i have to be at you know to get
to the high levels that i want to go and
to be able to see that firsthand be able
to you know pick his brain ask him
questions um learn from someone like mac
um that's that's an invaluable um
invaluable experience so i'm grateful i
had that learning opportunity how about
this year do you have contact with mac
and bounce ideas off him even this year
while he's going through his first
remarkable professional football season
yeah definitely yeah i was i just text
um who we were just texting yesterday
you know we've texted throughout the
year and again anytime i get to i get to
pick his brain and ask him hey what's it
like up there hey how did you maneuver
through this situation last year or how
did you how did you see this or him you
know just sharing his experiences or or
you know maybe seeing something on on on
a game like hey maybe this is a you know
this is something that um you know we
ran or i've learned but just to have mac
as a resource and to be able to even to
you know to this day to be able to to
text or call him about whatever it is
he's you know he's he knows and just be
able to pick his brain again even you
know to this day and beyond it's always
going to be
extremely beneficial for me to have him
as a resource bryce young of the
university of alabama right here on the
rich eisen show getting set to you so
you're heading to new york when tomorrow
is that when you're headed to tonight
late tonight very good uh safe journey
there as you go um uh to the heisman uh
trophy final and the ceremony um so a
question for you uh nick saban mentioned
rat poison i'm sure does he refer to it
as rat poison to you as he does to the
media does he refer to that yeah i think
we're all we're all just that's all just
um that's all just i've inscribed in our
brains at this point okay so he does
refer like that's the phrase he uses
with you and normally the rat poison is
what
to you yeah and normally it's yeah he
definitely uses me with all of us and
that's normally you know the media
talking about you know what we've done
well and normally the media you know
gassing us up about whatever
whether it be individually us as a team
normally that's you know normally that's
what he's referring to um and you know
this past weekend it was kind of a
different opportunity for us to where
we were kind of getting the opposite to
where a lot of people didn't believe in
us a lot of people um you know a lot of
people were kind of putting negative
things out there on
in the media about us and you know he
kind of talked to you know with that
press conference after the game you know
calling it you know calling the the
the home rat poison oh the yummy um he
was like
it was just it was yummy it was it was a
good opportunity for us to where we
normally it's about blocking out the
positivity in the media and blocking out
hearing oh you're you're this good
you're that good but this week it was
you know allowing us to to use that as
fuel and motivation and be able to kind
of earn our respect um so this week it
kind of worked in you know in a
different way than it normally does for
us so how did uh nick saban employ the
rat poison throughout the week leading
up to georgia how did he because again
this is as you pointed out a new thing
where he's actually letting you in on
what the media is saying as opposed to
saying drown it out
it makes his job tougher for for him to
be a coach to make sure you're focused
on the task at hand how did he employ
the rat poison this past week well yeah
i mean he doesn't normally he doesn't
even doesn't have to really really tell
us what people are saying you know he we
we always as a team and he's always
acknowledges that it's out there you
know he's we're you know we're all
we're you know it's you know in this day
and age we all see stuff and we all
we all hear stuff and
it's impossible and unrealistic for us
to just assume we never see anything and
it's and we're never going to hear what
the media says um
but really typically it's it's in the
past about it's just that challenge for
us to push it to push it out to block it
out and to even though it might be noise
in the background to make sure it stays
just that as noise but again this week
it was it was easier to where you know
again we had still all heard
all heard what the media was saying and
instead of us you know really having to
block it out and not feed into it we
kind of were able to um you know we kind
of were able to use his motivation and
again it was opportunity for us to to
earn our respect and it's something we
have to keep building off of so he
didn't specifically point something out
like here's something
yeah i mean there were there was there's
a few specifics but um again it wasn't
really that it wasn't really that
necessary for us again it was you know
you you hear what's going on we're all
conscious of what's going on it was just
us again about us just you know earning
that respect and getting back to the
standard that we always you know that
we're so big on so again
it's it's something that we have to keep
continuing to do and keep building on
for the future all right let's talk
about you for a little bit bryce young
um
there is no i there's a y uh there's no
i in bryce or young sellers too wise i
guess so at any rate uh who was your
quarterback growing up who was your guy
who said i want to be like this guy and
now here you are as a 20 year old
getting set to go to new york as the
heisman trophy finalist uh potential
winner on a team that's top-ranked going
into a college football playoff
yeah aaron rodgers has always been my my
favorite quarterback you know as long as
i've been a like a conscious student of
the game aaron rodgers always been
been my favorite quarterback someone
that i've looked up to someone that i've
definitely tried to emulate and
have a ton of respect for i'm just
seeing the stuff
he can do on the field seeing throws he
make he can make
you know a lot of the stuff
that you see on sundays from him is it's
crazy um so i've spent a good amount of
time you know
watching stuff and trying to learn what
i can just from you know watching games
on sundays or watching youtube cut ups
or whatever but um that's definitely you
know as long as i've been you know like
a conscious fan of the game that's
definitely been my favorite quarterback
what do you think you have in your game
that's uh that emulates his the
specifics what do you think um you know
i try i try to you know to emulate kind
of that that quick release that ability
to throw on and off platform um you know
he does a really good job of extending
plays
and a lot of times extending plays to
remain a passer
which is always a fine line and again
someone who
who when you do it so much sometimes it
can
you know then that's when you start
seeing him make runs downfield that you
know you're almost
you understand how you know how to get
that um you know that much space and and
it's because of how dangerous he is you
know extending the play um and remaining
a pastor so there's a lot of details
about his game that i try to emulate but
um yeah those are those are definitely a
few of them all right speaking of
emulating part of roger's game bryce
young i'll give you the floor do you
want to say you own georgia in the same
way he says
i'll give you that invitation you want
to say that
definitely die it's a week every time we
play a story program like that and such
a great it's a great team great
organization um again it's
you know any any success we have in the
past we know that it doesn't carry over
at all it's anything we have to earn
each one especially when you're talking
about a program and a team as good as as
george is you have to earn each one of
those wins and it comes from hard work
and preparation but it's it's every time
you know and it's really any game
especially with these games coming up um
anything that happens in the past um
it's it's a learning opportunity and you
can benefit off um you know you can
build off what you did well and you can
learn from what you did uh not as well
but um there's no you don't start with
any more points um on the board you have
to earn a win each and every week
that's with everyone
not only do you not accept the rat
poison you won't put any into the world
that is a well-coached
individual well done bryce young and in
that regard i'm going to ask you a
question i got a couple more for you
second the last one right here um i i've
asked this question of tool i've asked
this question of mac jones so now i get
to ask it of you
uh what's the angriest you've ever made
nick saban
what's the anger the most you've ever
pissed him off good question um
i was that let me think i think i would
say
i would say it was my freshman year
first game um i'd say it was probably my
freshman year first game missouri and um
when i first got here i had a big issue
with carrying the ball in high school i
would just run around with the ball with
one hand on the ball and i'd have one
hand on the ball almost in the pocket
all the time i'd have one hand on the
ball whenever i was extending plays
and
and coach saban would yell at me every
single time in a rep that i had it and
that was pretty often so i would get i
would get yelled at from from coach i
mean every two minutes i remember there
was one two men and this is again me as
a freshman um
we had won the two minute and i had
scrambled it and and found someone
downfield we wanted i was super happy
about it and i turned around and coaches
and you know and coach has nothing
positive to say he turns around and just
starts yelling at me about having the
ball out i'm in my head i'm thinking
like coach i got away i was fine i had
under control and the play worked but
you know
he was just worried about the ball out
so fast forward um missouri game um this
is kind of the end of the game it's my
first time playing in college and
um i think his second drive maybe first
second drive i step up try to try to
move to the right and again have one
hand on the ball and someone tackles me
gets the ball out it's a fumble and it's
like on there 35 40 so we have good
field position
and um i already knew go to what i got
up what i was going to have to hear on
the sideline so i'm jogging over and i
feel like i i know it wasn't that bad
but i felt like coach met me like at the
middle of the field um he was he was
he's livid just just be and you know
rightfully so it's something that he was
preaching on since i first got there and
something i kind of just followed to the
side is whatever whatever all whatever
i'm gonna make it work and then kind of
after that i realized like oh you know
what every all this all the all these
rings all these great teams this great
culture maybe coach knows a thing or two
so i've been i've been working on
improving that ever since
so do me a favor bryce if you are so
fortunate to win the heisman on saturday
you should show it to coach and say see
he's got it tucked in there
four points of pressure and that
football right there point to that
trophy
would you yeah that'll be that's any
time falls out good bad and ugly
whatever it is he's always you're always
gonna always gonna hear it from i love
it that's great and so speaking of the
heisman who's going with you who's part
of your your team your entourage that's
coming up there with you yeah it's gonna
be as far as you know like traveling
with me just you know it's just gonna be
my parents and then you know the
operation is here at the at the
university um but
um
yeah but as far as traveling with me i'm
on my way up there just uh my mom and my
dad that's so cool what they must be
just over the moon bryce right like this
is what uh you as a family have been
hoping for and achieving and you're in
the midst of it obviously on a roger a
20 year old at this
having succeeded and um to this point
that that must be amazing for you and
your family bryce truly it's okay yeah
no it's a blessing for sure um you know
i've as a family we've had a lot of you
know guys showing us a lot of favor and
i'm definitely blessed to be in the
circumstance that i am and i'm very
blessed to have the the parents that i
do you know to have a two-parent
household and have mom and a dad that
supported me and and you know and been
there you know by my side since you know
since literally i was born um for them
to you know them to to be here and
encourage me to you know a moment um as
big as this and
it's it's you know i'm i'm extremely
blessed bryce young what a pleasure to
meet you i hope it's the first of many
times i get to chat with you whether
it's collegiately or you know knock on
whatever for the next level
um have a great safe trip up to new york
and a great weekend and let's connect
over the next several weeks if you're up
for it sounds good thank you i
appreciate you having me on you bet that
is bryce young
of the university of alabama could not
be more
impressed
by a conversation right there that was
incredible oh boy okay so we have his
head screwed on straight
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here